the European Union is not a given the
European Union is work in progress and
indeed it is disintegration in progress
and a brexit would speed up this
disintegration and the speeding up of
this disintegration will create a
gigantic deflationary force a vortex
within continental Europe which will
consume Britain's I hear the Brits can
vote to get out but they cannot leave
the mess that will be left behind we
just ask you last Lee about the the
state of the eurozone you write the euro
zone's architecture was unable to
withstand the earthquake that we saw in
2008 we move from bailout to bail out to
bail out discussions of how to fix
things on a very short-term perspective
here we are in 2016 has there been
enough focus on reinforcing that
architecture so that if there is another
shock like we saw in 2008 the eurozone
could withstand it no we in a name we've
done all the right things we create the
european stability mechanism we created
a banking union that sounds perfect
except that if you look behind the the
acronyms and behind the facade what you
discover is that the european stability
mechanism is destabilizing the banking
Union exists only name not in practice
so for instance if you had 10 million
dollars or years you would really care
about whether they're in the Portuguese
back or in a German bank that's not the
banking Union when the probability of
being bathed in depends on which
jurisdiction you are you not talking
about the common currency anymore you
know talking about the common banking
Union the European Stability Mechanism
mechanisms being financed by CEO like
euro bonds where the every single one of
them is compartmentalized with different
chunks being backed by different states
with different interest rates and
different default probabilities and a
vicious correlation between the default
probabilities just like it element
brother serial so we every single time
with responded to sub crisis within
Europe by creating institutions a new
frameworks
the DNA of the problem was embedded
within the solutions that we found so
this is this is what I'm trying to
explain in the book that we there's been
a comedy of errors in India from the
last six seven years